and know when to welcome to see you're
playing your cheek GM yo chic yeah this
is one of the guys when I have a bad
score in turn wins six losses do you
usually play something crazy this is a
fairly normal by his standards yeah I
think be fired as a move on interesting
interesting Benko Kings Indian what not
okay I'm taking an and see what happens
night f4 maybe to d5 okay so i think
i'll go 25
so here Queenie for as an idea so he
probably I know maybe not but Queenie
and for can be an annoyance okay he
ignores that hmm ok so he thinks it's
not an annoyance why why not be 55 okay
maybe we should be five ed it's nothing
special and that's that's possible but
it's really possible but I still do it
yeah it might be okay if I'm oh yeah
very much very much possible p 1 yeah
then the spin is not such a big deal and
maybe he's got 95 here okay Queenie 5
bit over
uneasy moment damn yeah this is an
exchange sacrifice or blunder I don't
know we'll see what we see maybe he did
this on purpose it's possible he has
some some very he has something going
for him as well I'm trying the same so
rookie tonight at four that's definitely
possible so let's do this first I mean
if it did it on purpose it's a little
bit crazy but it's not completely
impossible okay so here gphone got this
no maybe going back here first
just want to control some more squares I
get 40 didn't expect that move thought
this would be kind of nice for me if I
get that in g5 and then activate the
bishop immediately he wants to get the
bishop to you five and sorry the knight
to e5 is what he tries to do which is
interesting that definitely
so we'll be sure to four or what I can
also play but should be too oppressive
g4 is interesting giving this up for
visually six check but it's firmly not
so convincing right hmm ok and I'll play
the conservative move surprising that he
went for this III was I didn't expect
this at all 93 maybe is that the thing
and maybe 93 as a problem don't like we
have one of course but maybe it tries
like Bishop b2 night c1 something crazy
crazy is wrong I mean something original
whatever you want to me and call it I
have to give the exchange bag of course
but I don't mind this this is a pretty
good position now
it's quite one-sided oh I can take it
well why did he allow that what's so
critical already I ok I didn't see this
one and still looks like dangerous
business and one minute 14 be sure the
subject the bishop is attacked the lamb
resigns who I could ya oh it's happy to
get a winning against because I've lost
many games where I was completely
winning from something weird and so on
who I don't know if he did he blunder ok
or sacrifice exchange I don't know it
yeah this and I think he is ok here if
he plays normal normal move I think
objectively this is not enough that's it
it's it's it's complicated stuff yeah my
idea was this activation probably I
think he is ok here f3 is just looks
looks a lot better this is I think
helping me a lot that I can now I can
move the rook and this is stable this is
probably a no as f3 is still given as ok
by the computer which slightly surprises
me why actually like this who gave aim I
guess looking for the time I don't get
f4 and
I sorry and age four I was thinking here
like age for Bishop age 3 as an idea but
he just has this and 194 came so I have
to do something normal let's say
somesome move like this no yeah okay and
he has enough still after a3 b3 and then
only this is getting into the big
trouble yeah the engine doesn't actually
want to do that which is pretty computer
risk decision Check Engine wants to play
this yeah because this is the winning
attack easily calculated by the computer
should not buy a human that this is
winning I mean okay if you see it like
this young hmm yeah it's made already
made in five but now i know i think what
i did there is okay just take it chat in
this position is excellent for while
it's just a question can you win or not
and it's probably a borderline ders
thing I don't know age 50 km/h
survivorship have seven is stronger but
this is cannot be bad has is also wins
yeah okay he dropped this but he is lost
here he has to move on to nit comb g6
maybe the room first covering this and
then take next threatening group age
seven made yeah interesting game here
against GM your shake thanks for
watching